House Republicans have officially kicked
ilhan Omar off the Foreign Affairs
committee and fellow Squad member AOC is
not happy about it
as also as a fellow New Yorker I think
one of the things that we should talk
about here is also one of the disgusting
legacies after 9 11 has been the
targeting and racism against Muslim
Americans throughout the United States
of America and this is an extension of
that Legacy consistency there is nothing
consistent with the Republican party's
continued attack except for the racism
and incitement of violence against women
of color in this body I had a member of
the Republican caucus threaten my life
and you all and the Republican caucus
rewarded him with one of the most
prestigious committee assignments in
this Congress don't tell me this is
about consistency don't tell me that
this is about an abdicate a condemnation
of anti-semitic remarks when you have a
member of the Republican caucus who has
talked about Jewish space lasers and an
entire amount of tropes and also
elevated her to some of the highest
committee assignments in this body this
is about targeting women of color in the
in the United States of America don't
tell me because I didn't get a single of
time has expiring my life was threatened
thank you
hey
AOC went on a rant there about herself
as she always does but let's get back to
the first part since we're here to talk
about ilhan Omar aoc's argument is that
ilhan Omar is the victim of islamophobia
which AOC cites as one of the worst
legacies of 9 11.
one of the worst Legacies
like you you think about 9 11 and you're
trying to identify the worst thing about
9 11 and the answer you come up with is
islamophobia AOC actually just performed
a Norm Macdonald bit on the floor of the
House of Representatives
I can't say my friend's name but he said
his biggest fear
is
that Isis or some terrorist group like
that would get a hold of a dirty bomb
and exploded over a major city within
the United States
and kill
tens of millions of people
because then
the blowback against
innocent Muslims would be absolutely
terrible
yes that's right that's true
okay let's do some jokes
that's it that would be the worst part
of it would be the blowback
the worst thing imaginable islamophobia
but islamophobia whatever that means is
not why ilahan Omar was removed from the
Foreign Affairs committee she was
removed because of the things that she
has said and done to prove that we can't
trust her with matters of foreign policy
and National Security good job ass
Republicans I'm Michael knowlesis the
Michael Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from lburg gallarga
who says Michael
myocarditis could definitely be from
eggs I saw the prices today and almost
had a heart attack you make a good point
you're it's probably worse than
myocarditis from the eggs it's just a
full-on at the grocery store heart
attack when people are paying nine
dollars for a dozen eggs it's crazy
sweet little Elisa actually texts and
calls me sometimes from the grocery
store to tell me how crazy the prices
are and when you want to text and call
your friends you got to check out pure
talk right now go to puretalk.com use
promo code Knowles if one of your goals
this year is to do business with
companies that hate your guts then
you're crazy you should do business with
companies that share what you believe in
that's why you got to check out Pure
Talk Pure Talk is the antidote to woke
wireless companies it is proudly veteran
owned it employs a us-based customer
service team
it refuses to spend money on fake news
networks not to mention Pure Talk
service is fantastic
one of the largest networks in the
country you get blazing fast data talk
and tax for as low as 30 bucks a month
probably half of what you're paying
Verizon ATT and T-Mobile switch over to
puretalk in as little as 10 minutes
while keeping your phone
and your phone number your first month
is guaranteed risk-free try it if you're
not completely happy with the service
you will get your money back this year
make it a goal to support companies that
support you go to puretalk.com enter
promo code Knowles Canada wlas to save
50 off your first month that is
puretalk.com promo code kwles Pure Talk
is simply smarter Wireless
the House Republicans were threatening
to do it now they've done it ilhan Omar
is off the Foreign Affairs committee
here's Kevin McCarthy explaining the
reasoning
now when it comes to congresswoman Omar
based upon what she had said the
anti-semitic comments
It's All About the Benjamins
the the military in America is equal to
Hamas and the Taliban on 9 11 something
happened that day even the former
Democratic chair of the committee
believed her comments were wrong when a
resolution was brought up to deal with
this last time she never apologized they
changed the resolution to say
anti-Semitism is wrong
we're not removing her from other
committees we just do not believe when
it comes to Foreign Affairs especially
the responsibility of that position
around the world with the comments that
you make
she shouldn't serve there but this is
what the clear this if it was Tit for
Tat we would have picked people took
them off all committees and said nothing
about we don't believe in that
all right that's the argument now the
first reason that Kevin McCarthy cites
for booting ilhan Omar off the Foreign
Affairs committee is her anti-semitism
and anti-Semitism very very bad I I
don't know if ilhan Omar hates the Jews
or not she very well might hate the Jews
but that would not be the primary reason
to kick somebody off the Foreign Affairs
committee and the reason for that is if
not liking the Jews is the threshold now
for kicking people off congressional
committees
there are probably some more people who
would have to be kicked off of
committees certainly in the Democratic
party certainly among the squad I think
that would probably take people out if
if not liking Israel
uh we're we're the bar there would be a
lot more people who would have to be
removed from their congressional
committees especially we're talking
about Israel very controversial facet of
foreign policy for the last century but
let's zoom out a little bit let's take
the Jews out of it for a second if
racial
or religious resentment were the new
threshold for kicking people off
congressional committees
you you'd have to lose probably half the
Democrat Party
how many Democrat members of Congress
have openly expressed antipathy for
white people said that whiteness is a
bad thing we need fewer white people in
in public life we we need less about
white people taught in schools
half the part more than half the party
what about antipathy toward Christians
half the party more than half the party
expressing a desire to to minimize the
role of Christianity in American public
life America a country founded on
Christianity that bar sorry to say is
probably too low for removing someone
from a congressional committee
racial or religious resentment you'd
probably lose most of the people on your
committees at least roughly half of them
no the reason the primary reason
that ilhan Omar should not serve on the
Foreign Affairs committee is not because
of what she said about one racial group
or about one religious group it's
because of what she said about America
and the enemies who have explicitly
attacked America
found it after 9 11.
because they recognize
people did something
and that all of us were starting to lose
access to our civil liberties the thing
that was interesting in the class was
every time the the the professor said
Al-Qaeda he sort of like his shoulders
went up and you know yeah
Al-Qaeda you know he's an expert
but it is it is that you don't say
America with an intensity you don't say
England with an intensity you know you
don't you don't say
um the army with an intensity
but you say these these names because
you you want that that word to carry
weight
Al Qaeda
Osama Bin Laden and it's so crazy right
I mean we say Al-Qaeda like it's big and
scary but we don't say the same thing
about America or the army so she's
saying that that if we view Al-Qaeda
with any more antipathy or fear then we
would view the United States and the
American Military then that's just sort
of silly it's we should be giggling
about that that's so crazy that's why
she should be removed from the
Committees
because she giggles at and seems to side
with America's enemies who have attacked
America
if we broaden this out too much and we
say well if you make a comment about
this racial group or this religious
group or this other Nation then that
disbars you from from serving on a
congressional committee then that gives
an opening to the Democrats it gives an
opening to AOC to say well Marjorie
Taylor green allegedly said something
about Jewish space lasers by the way
I've never heard this comment I've never
seen this comment I see it frequently
cited by the left but I've never heard
Marjorie Taylor green say anything that
makes me think she hates the Jews but
the the libs will use that they'll say
well look at this person look he's
expressed a kind of antipathy toward
this racial group or that religious
group or this that or the other thing
it's it's too low it's very clear it
doesn't need to be this this highly
emotional decision with AOC screaming
your head off and gesticulating like a
mad woman to to remove ilhan Omar
ilhan Omar has made light of the worst
terror attack in American history ilhan
Omar has taken the side of America's
enemies openly
the enemy is specifically involved in
that terror attack and she obviously has
no business on the Foreign Affairs
committee Kevin McCarthy cites those
comments as well he cites them a little
later down the line which I think is
what gives an opening to the Democrats
to criticize this decision this is an
obvious decision obviously this woman
should have absolutely nothing to do
with American National Security or
American foreign policy she was elected
by her constituents so I guess she
should continue to serve in Congress she
can even serve on some of the other
committees but get that lady away from
foreign policy and National Security
especially now as as we're in probably
the most fraught dangerous period for
National Security and foreign policy
certainly in 20 years maybe in a lot
longer than that maybe since the Cold
War as you see aggression from Russia
that threatens to destabilize Europe as
you're seeing aggression from China
which is now sending spy balloons over
the continental United States time to
reduce the threats to American National
Security including in the U.S Congress
all right I want to be able to rest easy
at night one great way to rest easy at
night you got to check out Pajamagram
right now go to pajamagram.com use promo
code nude
her
this Valentine's Day give her the gift
of silky naturally nude pajamas
available exclusively at Pajamagram even
more alluring than lingerie the texture
and touch of these pajamas are so soft
that you'll both love the feel of them
if you have no idea what to get your
girlfriend or wife for Valentine's Day
trust me she wants these pajamas go to
pajamagram.com right now and use code
nude
to save 25 off your order of naturally
nude pajamas Pajamagram will even wrap
the whole gift up for free listen here
if you missed out on this offer during
Christmas especially because they sell
out sometimes do not make the same
mistake twice give her naturally nude
pajamas but you need to order today last
year they sold out before Valentine's
Day they always do order them now
pajamagram.com use code nude
n-u-d-e for 25 off don't forget to tell
them that I sent you
speaking of vacating positions
Tom Brady has retired again
good morning guys I'll get to the point
right away
I'm retiring
for good
I know the process uh was a pretty big
deal last time so when I woke up this
morning I figured I just pressed record
and let you guys know first so I won't
be long-winded I think you only get one
super emotional retirement essay and I
used mine up last year so I really thank
you guys so much to every single one of
you
for supporting me my family
my friends my teammates
my competitors
I could go on forever there's too many
thank you guys for allowing me to live
my absolute dream
I wouldn't change a thing
love you all love you all now a year
after I retired
then came back I'm retiring again
I I don't have any uh particular care
that Tom Brady is retiring again I'm not
a New England Patriots fan I'm a New
Yorker by birth and upbringing I don't
watch football I don't even know what
team Tom Brady currently plays for or
did play for before he retired my
interest in this story goes back much
further than Tom Brady's football career
goes back way back to ancient days it
goes back to a man you might have heard
of a fella by the name of Hezekiah king
of Judah
Hezekiah king of Judah you can read
about him in the Bible
was a very good ruler
of Judah he was a very successful King
and one day the prophet Isaiah comes to
him and he says hey you're going to die
you're sick and you're gonna die and
your time has come and Hezekiah says oh
man I don't want to die Isaiah come on I
want to get can I give me some more
years come on talk to God get me some
more years
and Isaiah comes back and he says hey
you've been granted a reprieve God is
giving you another 15 years
and Hezekiah says oh man that's great
and what happens
Hezekiah
destroys his legacy
in that 15-year period Hezekiah welcomes
the Babylonians to come in check out his
kingdom check out all of his stuff if
they had had spy balloons during that
day the Babylonians would have been
sending that over although I guess they
didn't need to because Hezekiah just
invited them in and gives them a huge
upper hand in what would come later
which is the Babylonians just Conquering
the kingdom in that 15-year period of
time Hezekiah king of Judah has a son
his son is Manasseh Manasseh is a very
terrible King who tears down all the
great stuff that Hezekiah had done
and Hezekiah sees that this is going to
happen and Isaiah says you know man
things are going to go really South
you you were supposed to die but then
you know you got this little reprieve
and you're going to destroy everything
and what does Hezekiah say he says well
is this going to happen in my lifetime
Isaiah says no no it's going to happen
after you're dead and Hezekiah says oh
okay all right never mind well in that
case I get another 15 years it's pretty
nice right
was it worth it
I don't think so
and by the whole scope of Salvation
history you know it all all comes to a
purpose ultimately uh but in the moment
certainly wasn't good for Judah
certainly wasn't good for hezekiah's
legacy
certainly wasn't good
certainly wasn't good for Tom Brady
a real important reminder
know your time
know when things are over Tom Brady
could have retired a year ago he would
have gone out as the almost universally
beloved greatest football player of all
time with a super hot wife that people
generally liked and a nice family and he
could have rode off into the sunset
instead he decided to unretire this has
been broadly cited as the reason why his
wife divorced him and lost him a lot of
favor among the fans and for what
to get one more year and then he says
okay I'm out
was it worth it to just wring out
another few months of playing football
probably not was it worth it Hezekiah
just to ring out another 15 measly years
on Earth you destroy the kingdom of
Judah I don't think so
now I mentioned I mentioned those uh
hostile foreign powers coming in and
spying around on on kingdoms this is a
story that just broke last night the the
Chinese have apparently sent a spy
balloon over the continental United
States my first reaction is
is this 1952 or we we're still sending
spy balloons
don't we have more advanced technology
than that don't the Chinese Chinese are
very Advanced they stole all of our Tech
surely surely the Chinese have more
advanced Tech than this apparently not
so there's this spy balloon
and it's it's going over here and the uh
foreign affairs spokesman for the
Chinese whose name is Mao not a good
sign also mounding Mao says I want to
stress that before it becomes clear what
happened to any deliberate speculation
or hyping up will not help the Chinese
side is gathering the facts and hopes
all sides will handle this matter in a
cool headed manner
we act in accordance with international
law says Ming or says Mao ning I kind of
push those two together it says Mao ning
we have no intention to violate any
other country's sovereignty and bearing
the facts we hope relevant parties would
handle the matter in a clear-headed way
yeah okay yeah China famous for acting
in accordance with international law
China which starting the moment we let
them into the World Trade Organization
starts violating all the trade rules
steals all of our technology
artificially subsidizes steel and
aluminum aluminum artificially
manipulates its currency just does
everything it can to violate
international law to say nothing of what
it does to various population groups
within China and just all the heinous
things that the regime inflicts on its
people
yeah we act in accordance with
International a lot so what is the Biden
Administration doing
now the Biden Administration I was
wondering I said okay what is this
balloon look like and we don't know
exactly because it's still flying
overhead
what they said they're monitoring the
situation they're they've got eyes on it
they're monitoring the Spy balloon are
you kidding me
are you is this the depth of weakness
that the United States has sunk to
that we see a spy balloon flying over
the continental United States
we know it's from
our most threatening geopolitical foe
China
and we just let it keep flying we don't
shoot this thing down
what are we spending all this money on
in the US Military
all that defense spending that we get
every year we can't even shoot down a
stupid balloon good grief man
you know back in the 50s
when the U.S was sending spy planes over
the Soviet Union
when there was a a far greater risk of a
nuclear war than you have right now
between America and the United States or
in America and China rather what what
did the Soviet Union do they shot the
plane down
the plane which wasn't just a random
balloon the plane that had a pilot in it
and the U.S denied oh no we don't have
any spy plans over the Soviet Union and
then they shoot down the plane and we
say okay all right I guess we did
and now
we're so afraid of upsetting China that
we'll let that we will allow them
to send a spy balloon over the U.S good
grief
the reason we're doing it of course is
because China sort of owns us at this
point
they own a ton of our debt
they own our entire
production line they own our supply
chain
they if they cut us off if we're a
little too aggressive with China
well then
then we're screwed
this is what happens for a long time
you heard people on among the liberal
free Trader types especially Joe Biden
he was really clear about this he said
oh we need to bring China into the
International Community we need to trade
with them a rising tide lifts All Ships
it's really good Rising shine is good
for everybody
you know what let's let's give them all
of our manufacturing yeah I know that'll
hurt small town Americans that'll hurt
blue-collar Americans but that's doesn't
matter because now we'll get cheap junk
from China and that'll be really really
great for everybody and there's no
downside to Total free trade and
offshoring and Outsourcing there's no
downside at all because GDP might tick
up a little bit this is what you heard
from the free Traders not just in the
Democrat Party in the Republican party
too and there were some people some of
those less fashionable figures who said
actually maybe we need some
Manufacturing in the U.S actually maybe
it's not going to Outsource our entire
manufacturing base actually maybe
tariffs wouldn't be the worst idea
actually maybe we should counter China's
rise and these people were laughed at as
Rubes economically illiterate stupid
idiots
and now now what situation are we in
we're in a situation where
China calls the shots
because he who pays the piper calls the
tune GDP is not everything free trade is
not universally good at all times in
every way and actually it might serve
the purposes of National Security might
serve our national political flourishing
for us to be able to make some things
ourselves and not be totally owned and
operated by our enemies
you know Jeremy's razors is offering a
great deal that ends tonight at midnight
40 off all razors why the discount I'm
glad you asked a year ago
when Joe Biden tried to force a vaccine
mandate upon private employers and some
85 million Americans the daily wire told
them where to stick it we've sued the
federal government and we won after a
6-3 ruling in our favor at the Supreme
Court the Mandate was dead together we
kicked the government's derriere so on
the first anniversary of this tremendous
victory for all Americans the daily wire
CEO and God King Jeremy boring has
issued a special decree on the razors
that bear his name 40 off all razors
that means that you can get a Precision
5 razor with flipback trimmer shave
cream post-shaped bomb extra blades and
a handy travel case for just
35.99 that's a savings of 24 bucks
very very good deal the Biden
Administration and its awful cronies
were cut down now we Rejoice by slurping
up their leftist tears we enjoy our
freedom and we look damn good doing it
now is your last chance to get 40 off
all Jeremy's razors by going to Jeremy's
razors.com today Jeremy's racers.com
this weekend by the way yes or no the
internet's greatest interview show and
game is back with special guest Michael
malis I am certain that you're all very
excited to watch me sit down with a
fellow Michael you know sharing a first
name is not quite like being a family
but you can bring the fun home to your
family with yes or no the game it's
available now for pre-order at
dailywire.com shop it's sold out
instantly last year now is your chance
to pre-order a copy this is going to
sell out as well I we've ordered
thousands more copies it's selling very
very fast it is filmed filled with
harmful
conspiracy-like content all the sorts of
things YouTube won't like yes or no
tests your knowledge of those closest to
you do you really know your friends and
family where do they land on core issues
like is virtue more important than our
shallow understanding of Freedom get to
the bottom of it all including your
glass with yes or no the game head on
over to dailywire.com shop to secure
yours today
speaking of national rulers
the GOP every year well both parties
every year give a response to the State
of the Union
party and power has the president giving
the State of the Union before Congress
and then the opposition party
errors a response on TV
and it's a terrible job
it's a terrible job and it's it's much
smaller and it doesn't look nearly as
cool and it pretty much Dooms the
political career or whoever gives it
which is why I'm really sorry to see
that Sarah Sanders is giving the
response this year because I really like
Sarah Sanders I think she is a
tremendous politician I think her head
and her heart are in the right place I
think she could be a great national
leader she already is she's the governor
of Arkansas and so I wish her the best
of luck I think she's just terrific
but that's too bad I really like I hope
the curse does not hold this year I'm
sure she'll do a great job I'm sure
she'll do as good a job as you possibly
can at the State of the Union response
but
not a great gig now it gets even worse
because the GOP is not only giving the
usual response to the State of the Union
the GOP is giving two responses
they're giving one from Sarah Sanders
that will be in English
then they're giving another response in
Spanish
ah this is from the House GOP
it's from from uh this this guy what's
his name Juan Cisco Money he's a
congressman he is going to deliver the
Spanish response he and his family
immigrated to the U.S loves America he
hates wokeness
and so he's gonna talk about how
important it is to vote for republicans
and Espanol
I have nothing against Juan saskamani I
don't know Juan ciscomani he's got six
kids and is a republican so seems like a
great guy I bet he's terrific this is a
terrible idea
what the hell are we conserving
we can't even conserve the language that
we all speak the most basic aspect of
our
political culture
it's the most that's the most basic
aspect we are a self-government we're a
republic the way a republic governs
itself is by speaking to one another and
by debating
and persuading one another it almost
nothing unifies Us in the United States
we
in the early days were broadly unified
by race broadly unified by religion
broadly unified by the experience of the
Revolution broadly unified even by bonds
of family I mean the fact that the
pilgrims when they came over there were
so few of them and many of them died in
that first winter if you if you trace
back people who are of the lineage for
of the Mayflower
usually they'll have not One Mayflower
ancestor but but many because they all
married each other and they so everybody
was kind of a cousin with one another
well that's gone that's gone that's
that's been falling away for a very long
time in American history and you've also
had Mass migration which has complicated
this so okay you no longer are unified
by Family by race in recent decades
you're no longer unified by religion
you've had huge waves of non-Christian
migrants and and Christianity among the
native population has declined as well
so you're not unified by that people are
not unified even by the national symbol
anymore the American flag half the
country protests the American flag so
the most basic thing you could be
unified by is the language that you
speak but we can't even speak to each
other anymore and it's not the Democrats
the Democrats aren't issuing a Spanish
state of the union
they're not going to have some Spanish
official go up and here's the Spanish
version of Biden's speech now it's us
it's the Republicans it's so pathetic
for what
for what to to Pander to people who will
be they can turn on sap okay they can
they can read the speech if they want in
Spanish
that you could dub it over whatever
Sarah Sanders has to say
but no we're the ones doing we're gonna
we're gonna out woke the woke
we're so clever oh Democrats they're the
real
anti-immigration Advocates Democrats are
the real Hispanic phobes give me a break
it's so pathetic so so pathetic speaking
of live streaming
this story I meant to get to yesterday
I'm glad we have time to get to it today
you probably did not read this story
it's a weird one a twitch streamer
so you know we don't put our show out on
Twitch I'm not young and hip and cool
enough for that but twitch is where all
the cool hip youths go to play video
games and just stream and have kind of
parasocial relationships a twitch
streamer
was just caught viewing a kind of porn
of some of his friends who are also
twitch streamers
that's weird enough I mean just getting
caught looking at porn is embarrassing
enough
then getting caught looking at porn of
your friends very very embarrassing
your friends
that that was generated by artificial
intelligence probably the creepiest
weirdest most embarrassing of all
a guy who
a Heroes by the name atriak he posted
this very tearful apology video because
he got caughty he was streaming his
phone or his computer and it zoomed out
and it showed he had some tabs open and
the tabs had this weird pornup and it
was deep fake porn
of a couple of other streamers whose
names I won't say so that some of you
naughty people in the audience don't go
look it up but it it is a
it's a kind of porn where I guess you
you plug in totally wholesome pictures
and videos of these people and then the
computer it's not just that the computer
grafts it onto some other naked lady's
body it generates a model of the person
and then the AI engineer you can tell
what a Luddite I am by the way I'm
talking about this but the the AI
engineer can then manipulate the body to
engage in whatever depraved acts the the
guy wants it to
on top of that there was an announcement
this week that another AI company has
just made huge leaps in AI voice so you
can plug in audio of a person talking
and plug in a clip from the show and
then you can
analyze the voice create a model of it
type in a prompt and then make the voice
say whatever you want the voice to say
so now you can totally mimic somebody's
voice and capture it totally mimic
somebody's body and capture it and by
the time they they perfect the sex
robots I think the human race is going
to go extinct
that's it right because because
then you will have had the Perfection of
anti-social Behavior
all of this especially the AI porn of it
all is the most anti-social Innovation
since the radio
it just gives you an opportunity to feel
like you're having a social interaction
without really doing so
previously for most of human history if
you wanted to have a social interaction
you had to talk to people
then in the 20th century you could just
kind of turn on the radio and you could
hear people but you still weren't
interacting with them then TV is more
immersive than the internet's more
immersive but now if you have a crush on
a girl
in the old days in the early old days
you'd write love poetry about the girl
even if you didn't know her that well I
always go back to Dante Dante saw this
girl Beatrice twice and he writes all
this love poetry about her and she's
this great Muse right it's really
elevating and lifts his spirits up all
the way to heaven now if you have a
crush on a girl you don't even need to
ever meet the girl you don't even need
to ever talk to the girl you can just
take a video and an audio clip of her
plug it into the computer and make her
do whatever you want so so deeply
anti-social
and it's it's not exactly new it's just
the acceleration of a trend that is
further isolating all of us from one
another even as we're packed more
closely together in cities cities are
growing by Leaps and Bounds within the
next 10 to 20 years you will have the
majority of people in the world living
in cities whether they want to or not
that's just how the trend lines are
moving and yet we know each other so
much less we can interact with each
other so much less we can now create a
simulacrum of being as intimate with
somebody as two bodies can be never meet
the person in our lives
now I want to be intimate with you not
like the creepy twitch people but in the
mailbag this mailbag is sponsored by
Pure Talk go to puretalk.com today
select a plan enter code Knowles Canada
wlas to get 50 off your first month
take it away with the first voicemail
back question
hi Michael Aaron here with a question
ideally suited to the author of
speechless controlling words controlling
Minds available for purchase everywhere
I am a member of a conservative online
community consisting of like-minded
individuals mostly daily wire
subscribers we recently had a new member
who very quickly espoused Nazi ideology
and I don't simply mean that I happen to
disagree with this person on some finer
points of politics I mean this person
actually denies the Holocaust he thinks
that far fewer than 6 million Jews died
he thinks uh that that their deaths was
a good thing and that Jews control
Western Civilization to its detriment
now he was banned for these comments but
being friends with the owner of this
community I ask that he be reinstated
and it wasn't because I in any way
sympathize with his views I I abhor such
beliefs but I was concerned that if we
excise him from our community he will
find a new community consisting of truly
violent despicable people who will
indoctrinate them fully into Nazi
ideology and frankly I would rather he
be exposed to the Michael Knowles show
than to such individuals
I'm curious do you think I made the
right decision uh how would you act if
you were in my place as always I would
appreciate your wisdom thank you
Arun as usual you are correct I think I
think you're correct you know that I am
no free speech absolutist I do not
believe that Nazis have any right to
espouse their views I'm with Bill
Buckley who said in the 60s that he's an
epistemological optimist who doesn't
believe that there's any reason to
protect Nazis or Communists in the
Public Square
there's no pressing reason to throw them
into prison but there's no protection to
keep them out of prison exactly either
but as a Prudential matter I think
you're right
especially on this question
because you're seeing the uh antipathy
toward the Jews bubbling up a little bit
more than usual even right now and I
mean ilhan Omar just got kicked off a
congressional committee because of it
and so I I think it is important not to
Silo people who hold those views
even further I think your reasoning is
absolutely right
there are many good reasons not to like
the Nazis they're they're antipathy
toward the Jews certainly one of them
but many many others too the Nazis were
into weird occult rituals the Nazis were
about enemies of the church Pope Pius
XII wonderful Pope viewed the church as
the victim of of the Nazis even before
the second world war and so so uh
there are there are many reasons to
oppose that kind of an ideology it's
very modern ideology that comes out of
all sorts of terrible views I mean this
is true fascism is different from Nazism
but people forget with fascism as well
fascism comes out of socialism and
actually Benito Mussolini who is the
figurehead of fascism who's probably the
most most important figure in all of
fascism he was a socialist intellectual
for much of his formative years and so
it's just I think it's important to
answer these kinds of questions
and if you can do so in a level-headed
way and say hey here's why it's not good
to be a Nazi here's all the bad things
the Nazis did and why you shouldn't
admire them and you don't get
totally you know ecstatic about it and
you don't become like AOC flailing your
arms around you just answer in a very
reasonable way I think that that is
going to do a lot to get people off the
wrong track that they are on whereas as
you say if if the moment that anyone
utters any kind of uh
nazi-esque kind of intimation or
question no matter how ill-formed or
bizarre the person is if the moment that
happens they're instantly ostracized
from all of society they're going to
take that as as confirmation that their
intuitions were correct and as you say
they're going to find themselves in in
more and more uh
sordid communities you know they'll be
in that that Hive of villainy in in Star
Wars and so I totally agree with you I
think uh especially as a Prudential
matter on this question
yeah hear people out answer their
questions knock down the bad points that
they have to make next question
hey Michael I just had a question
concerning one of my really close
friends recently she came out as a
lesbian and I know in the past you've
said that you know guys and girls can't
be best friends because there's probably
going to be feelings there which I
completely understand but is it the same
with my really close girlfriend if
technically she is attracted to me
because she is a lesbian
um love your show and thanks for all you
do
well I think you flatter yourself are
you sure that your friend is attracted
to you
specifically maybe she is you sound like
a very lovely attractive person so maybe
she is but I don't think it's quite as
big a deal
one because
homosexual attraction is
a kind of an odd thing
this is especially true for female to
female uh same-sex attraction
there are all sorts of reasons behind it
it's it's quite unclear uh how these
things develop and it's it doesn't track
the same way that two guys who are
attracted to each other tracks and
certainly doesn't track the same way
that normal sexual relations track so I
wouldn't worry about it too much
especially that you are not a lesbian
and so you are not going to be attracted
to her one of the reasons that single
men and single women
struggle to be platonic friends is
because there is a natural attraction
one to another
uh that that is going to come up
or even a married woman and a single man
or a married man and a single woman is
there's going to be a natural kind of
attraction that is mutual that bubbles
up here I I don't think I I don't think
that's true especially look I'm from New
York I went to the gayest University in
the world I lived in Los Angeles and I'm
friends with a lot of people in Show
Business a disproportionate number of my
friends are of the homosexual
inclination okay but I'm I've never said
well I can't be friends with you because
you might be attracted to me because one
I'm I am not attracted to that person so
it's not not a problem for me and I I
just don't
I I don't think those the the moment
that your friend for instance says I'm a
lesbian now she's gonna you know pounce
on you or throw you on a bed I don't I
don't think that's really the way it
works so I think you're okay you should
be much more cautious about about being
close friends with a married man you
know going out having dinner with him
than with your uh lesbian friend next
question
what's up Michael second time calling in
love your show anyways
um I am Christian now I had kind of gone
away from the church and I'm back and
now I'm really getting in and reading
the Bible and looking at theology at a
more deep level and something that I've
come across in the Bible a lot is I
didn't really realize how much Jesus
talks about hell I mean he says he's
going to separate the good fish from the
bad fish and he says why does the road
of Destruction and narrow is the gate to
eternal life and there's all these
people out there on the internet
freaking out about everybody going to
hell but then there's also people who
say everybody's going to be saved and
not that you know who's going to be
saved and who's not going to be saved
but do you think going to hell is
something we should all be freaking out
about all the time I'll be worried about
and it should be our number one priority
stopping that I guess it should be our
number one priority to stop that but
should we worry about it all the time
yes
though in in the kind of flip way of
what you're talking about your concern
all the time should be
uh knowing god loving him serving him in
this life and enjoying him forever in
heaven
that should be your concern it's not so
much that you're running away from hell
but that you should run toward God
this is actually expressed in the act of
contrition which is the prayer that one
says after confession
one says I'm you I'm sorry God I'm sorry
that I've sinned and I'm I'm sorry and I
hate my sins not just because I dread
the loss of Heaven and the Pains of hell
but because my sins offend you whom I
should love Above All Things
and so it you can have imperfect
contrition
for your sins which is just man I don't
want to burn in hell or man I don't want
to miss out on heaven but perfect
Contrition is when you are sorry for
your sins because they are sins and
because sins offend God and because you
love God and you don't want to offend
God uh
so imperfect Contrition can be an
important step the fear of hell is
important and Christ talks about as you
say Christ talks about hell in in the
gospels a lot
hell hell is a real thing and you should
not want to go there
uh
and you should allow that healthy fear
to turn you toward
the holy fear so there is a kind of
servile fear where you're just afraid of
pain or you're afraid of being harmed
and then there is there is Holy fear or
awe or wonder wisdom where you're just
marveling before God your your
perceiving Sublimity and and your
you're in awe of that and that
cultivates humility and will will impel
you to do the right thing and to serve
God that's good and you should go to
confession that's that's another very
important thing to do it's the
laundromat for the soul next question
hey Michael this is Camille again and
yes I have another dating question for
you I keep finding myself attracted to
the wrong type of guy I swear I'm not
looking just at looks and I'm not
looking at superficial things but I do
keep finding myself attracted to guys
who seem nice and then end up being
jerks so I would love to hear your
thoughts on how to find the better guys
and be attracted to them and not force
things though thanks Michael
great question Camille one that I'm sure
many women struggle with many such cases
the the reason that you are attracted to
these bad guys is because your desire
and Will are disordered
but
it is not the case that your desire per
se is wrong this is I think a place
where a lot of people go awry they say
the fact that I have desire
for these men is wrong in and of itself
no no the desire is good
the way that you advance in wisdom and
sanctity in your whole life is going to
be through your desire it's not going to
be by suppressing your desire it's got
to be through your desire but your
desire is aimed at the wrong place right
now so we people have sexual desire
often in this Fallen World especially if
one is uneducated and one indulges in a
lot of advice then that sexual desire is
going to express itself in the form of
lust so you're just going to desire
hot chicks or in your case big hunky hot
dudes and you're going to focus just on
that on that on the sensation and and
not on the intelligible
right you're going to focus on just what
feels kind of good and not what that
good feeling is meant to represent not
the not the the real intelligible
goodness that is behind the phenomena
and so what you'll want to do is turn
your desire you recognize that you're
let's say physical attraction to some
big hunky jerk of a dude
that that is an a an intimation
of of a good desire for a good man so
lust which is shallow and bad and will
mess you up
is really a perversion of Love of true
love which Wills the good of the other
person and seeks the good generally
gluttony is just a perversion and a
disorder of a perfectly healthy and good
desire to sustain ourselves and to have
food to allow us to keep going in this
life
Pride the queen of all vices is just a
it's sort of the the original big
problem and it is a disorder and a
perversion of self-confidence and so you
might be attracted to a guy who's very
prideful he's very cocky well it's
probably because you you would have a
natural and good desire for a man who is
confident and why would he be confident
because he is in charge of himself he's
suppressed his base appetites he's he's
in somewhat some command of his rational
will he's doing good things he's
flourishing he can be confident
cockiness is is a a a
sad shallow imitation of confidence and
so what you I think what you need to do
is when you feel that movement of your
appetite and and that attraction toward
a certain kind of a sensation you should
just recognize the rational and
intelligible thing that that that desire
ultimately should be drawn you toward
and and and then you will better be able
to discern between some cocky jerk and
some confident Alpha Chad Giga totally
virtuous guy and then rationally choose
the latter because it will fulfill the
thing that your desire is ultimately for
it's just but it's not not quite aiming
at right now because it's gone a little
bit awry today's fake headline Friday I
need your help to figure out which one
of these five headlines is the fake one
you have to do that over on the member
block we will be taking more of your
mailbag questions too including some of
the OG written mailbag questions
the show continues now
not for you Hoy polloi over on YouTube
but for the creme de La Creme the Inner
Circle at dailywire.com
at checkout you get two months free on
all annual plans we will see you there
[Music]
foreign